so that's Trump at CPAC let's now talk
about everybody else at CPAC just to
sort of close the loop on it closing the
loop on the weaponization of ignorance I
have a clip for you that is a mere 72
seconds long where there are five people
competing for the dumbest comment of the
entire weekend at CPAC on stage you have
Donald Trump jr. you have charlie Kirk
from Turning Point USA you have Donald
Trump juniors I guess his girlfriend
former Fox News anchor kimberly
guilfoyle and then two other clowns I
think I think one guys matched lap and
then some other woman you don't even
have to know who they are but they are
all on the CPAC stage trying to be
clever CPAC 2019 set the record for the
dumbest comments that the crowd went
absolutely bonkers for a quick note a
lot of lip service paid to guns at CPAC
of course it's a gun-free zone no guns
allowed why because it would be insane
to let's at thousands of conservatives
carrying guns into a room with each
other obviously so all about guns no
guns allowed at CPAC that gets us to
some of the panel's check out this first
video and tell me who do you think is
the dumbest here three weeks ago
tomorrow we had our second granddaughter
and like I said a few weeks ago yeah and
her name is Reagan how presidential is
that beautiful Reagan Elise I lobbied
for Trump but it was a little too soon
maybe so we'll see Trump is not the most
feminine name that we could make it
playbook it doesn't matter you know it
doesn't matter we can identify how we
want okay so I mean I guess you can call
your kid whatever you want obviously I
guess the joke is that it's a reference
to trans people existing and that I
guess counts as funny during CPAC on the
CPAC stage in front of that crowd so now
we continue with this new grandmother
explaining gender to the crowd by the
way she is a daughter she's our
granddaughter she's a dime we're raising
her as a girl she's we're not
let her have a choice she's outraged
tomorrow that you decided for God God
makes the choice of what the babies are
gonna be and God decided she would be a
girl you know so this is just
straight-up transphobia right I mean
this is this is a dumb conversation it's
a very stupid conversation and by the
way she's gonna have a choice I hate to
break it to you some day she'll be an
adult and she'll be able to make
decisions for herself unless you
literally enslaved the girl so now it's
getting very very dumb like this out
does Donald Trump jr. but then I think
it gets even dumber than what Don jr.
said but it comes from the other dude on
stage take a listen you don't have to
raise them as a girl she just got a
little baby doll right there arm every
second I mean my boys always had guns in
their hands we didn't that's not
something hashtag me too that's not
something you teach them that's
something they're born with but as far
as those cows you mentioned I've got 100
cows you just let it Alexandria Cortez
show up at my house and try to take my
cows away yes I love cows Jerry they're
delicious
yes sir that guys that's Jerry that's
not match slap I don't know who that guy
is is that Jerry Falwell Jr I don't even
know I've no clue who that guy is but
what he's saying is if a baby holds a
doll they will be a woman and his kids
held guns so they are men and then he
talked about what Alexandria Cortez I
don't know who that is
Alexandria Cortez referring to a OC
obviously a OC recently said it would be
better if everybody ate fewer burgers
and now there's this meme that
Alexandria Acacio Cortez wants to take
people's cows and it's a real Sophie's
Choice here trying to say who said the
most ignorant stuff here and I don't
know pat whether the most disturbing
element of this is that CPAC chose to
make this a panel or that CPAC was right
the audience would love it and they did
I think the most disturbing element is
that Donald Trump jr. thinks he's the
comedian now like we know from the
Michael Cohen testimony that Trump
thinks that his own son has the worst
judgment of all time I think that comes
true that rings true when he's trying to
make jokes there and they completely
fall flat other people had to fake
laughs in order for it to keep going
yeah I mean just sucking the air
directly out of the room so that's that
panel but that's not all then we get to
this outrageous congressman mark meadows
who literally brought in a black woman
as a political prop during the michael
cohen hearings he opened up also by
talking about alexandria Acacio cortez
conspiracies and chick-fil-a you know
with this green new deal they're trying
to get rid of all the cows but I've got
good news
chick-fil-a stock will go way up need
more chicken all right I mean so okay
and then Ted Cruz also talking about
killing cows which really seems to miss
a o'seas point altogether obviously I
hope to see PETA supporting the
Republican Party now that the Democrats
want to kill all the cows
[Applause]
chicken and beef now the subject of CPAC
chicken and beef really an entire
weekend of idiocy weaponized ignorant
cognitive dissonance and unfortunately
people who came away feeling invigorated
this stuff I've been to conventions like
this people experienced this stuff and
they come away invigorated like it was
just the most amazing experience it's
almost like a spiritual experience for
people who attend and they now come out
strengthened their beliefs strengthened
that their harebrained ideas and
completely backwards logic and morality
is the way forward and I would not be
surprised if it actually leads to more
erratic behavior in the real world not
just from the people who attended but
also from the speakers because you go
out there and you see this rabid crowd
hungry for transphobia and jokes about
socialism and communism and all this
stuff they come away like wow our
movement is really something we are now
going to get even wackier in the real
world and that's already what you're
seeing in the short time since this
event I'm on Twitter if you want to send
me your thoughts what exactly is the
defining characteristic of CPAC in your
mind I'm on Twitter at D Pakman and the
show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
today's program is sponsored in part by
Blink accom slash Pakman if you've not
already heard about blink Asst it's
amazing it's an app for your phone
tablet or web browser and what they do
is they take nonfiction books popular
nonfiction critically acclaimed
nonfiction they condense the book into a
15 minute audio book you get all the
most important information and insights
from each book but you can soak up the
entire essence of the book in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blinkin recent one is a Robert Rice's
new book the common good also bunk by
Kevin Young useful in preparing me for
the pseudo-science miniseries that we're
producing and if you are a david pakman
show viewer or listener you can get a
seven day free trial by going to blink
komm slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube use the link in the video
description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about 5 bucks a
month that's be Li NK is t.com /pa ke ma
n